Все вы знаете что доходы и результаты
разных людей очень сильно разнятся
причём эта разница может составлять
десятки сотни а то и тысячи
процентов кто-то зарабатывает 10.000
долларов в год а другие в это время
зарабатывают сотни и миллиарды причём у
них у всех во рабочих часов в день 24
часа в сутках и 365 дней в году самое
главное у них нет никаких генетических
различий и различий в об мозга и памяти
Как вы думаете почему так
происходит вот сегодня мы и поговорим о
различных уровнях эффективности и о том
как разбивать стеклянные потолки вы не
будете расти и достигать крутых
результатов Если вы не будете знать об
этом вы постоянно будете упираться в
стеклянный потолок своего развития
потому что не будете понимать что в
эффективности существуют различные
уровни
и они кстати не зависят от вашего
усердия количества проведенного времени
на работе и от ваших талантов и
способности для того чтобы хорошо
зарабатывать и жить гармоничной жизнью
человеку достаточно ми рабочих часов в
день или 2000 часов в год я не верю в
работу по 14 часов в день если человек
работает столько времени значит он
однозначно неэффективен Причём я имею в
виду не только его работу а вообще
способ ни таким человеком если человек
работает по 14 часов в день то это
значит что у него проседают другие сферы
это может быть либо за счёт здоровья
либо за счёт семьи либо за счёт общения
с друзьями и
близкими это видео для тех кто достиг
определённых успехов и результатов Но
перестал расти дальше для тех кто не
может понять почему при возрастающих
усилиях и рабочем времени у него не
растут результаты и чувствует что он
упёрся в стеклянный потолок для тех кто
хочет понять почему существует такая
Огромная разница В результатах разных
людей это видео для тех кто хочет
большего поняв Почему Одни люди
достигают колоссальных результатов а
другие Нет вы наконец сможете пробить
свой стеклянный потолок и выйти на новый
уровень своих доходов и достижений вы
поймёте Где выход как выйти за рамки
своих ограничений вы увидите что вы были
как та самая муха которая безостановочно
бьётся в стекло пытаясь его пробить В то
время как рядом была открытая дверь если
вы хотите добиться всё возрастающих
результатов без увеличения рабочего
времени и нагрузки вам нужно досмотреть
это видео до конца это видео откроет вам
глаза и даст вам сильный скачок
мотивации подписывайтесь на мой канал
ставьте колокольчик активно
комментируйте и делитесь этим видео с
людьми которых вы считаете амбициозны и
теми кто пашет день и ночь а результаты
не впечатляют поверьте они будут вам
очень
благодарны мы все хотим больших
результатов и больших доходов потому что
наши результаты и доходы формируют наш
уровень жизни в погоне за большими
результатами и большими доходами мы
начинаем работать дольше и усерднее в
начале у каждого человека идёт прямая
корреляция между его усердием
продолжительностью рабочего дня и его
доходами и Это первый уровень на этом
уровне размер вашего дохода напрямую
зависит от вашего таланта способностей
личной эффективности усердия и
продолжительности рабочего дня чем
больше любого из этих компонентов тем
выше ваш доход именно на этом уровне
находятся наёмные работники и фрилансеры
Итак вы работаете больше И дольше и ваши
доходы растут
какой-то момент рост ваших доходов
начинает замедляться а потом и вовсе
останавливается Несмотря на то что вы
только увеличиваете свою усердие и
рабочее время Вот тут-то вы и упирается
в свой первый стеклянный потолок
стеклянный потолок - это отсутствие
роста несмотря на увеличение усилий и
времени вы пробуете и так и эдак Однако
всё четно доходы больше не растут Для
дальнейшего роста ваших доходов Вы
должны начать делать что-то по-другому
или делать что-то другое Ключевое здесь
- это делать что-то по-другому или
делать что-то другое именно это и
является способом пробития стеклянного
потолка Каждый раз когда ваши результаты
перестают расти невзирая на рост ваших
усилий начните делать те же самые вещи
но по-другому или начните делать что-то
другое это и есть открытая дверь через
которую вы можете вырваться на следующий
уровень дальше Вы понимаете что
самостоятельно работать неэффективно и
одному всё сделать невозможно и вы
начинаете нанимать себе помощников и
других людей так зарождается бизнес И
следующий уровень вашей эффективности
уже будет определяться тем какого уровня
делегирования вы сможете достичь
существует три уровня делегирования
первый уровень - это делегирование
это когда вы говорите человеку что
делать когда где и как а потом вы
принимаете работу и выплачиваете ему
заработную плату за выполненную работу
второй уровень делегирования - это
делегирование достижения результата или
решение проблем Это когда вы говорите
человеку как действовать и какой
результат вы хотите в конце получить а
потом принимаете результат и
выплачиваете ему премию или бонус третий
уровень - это делегирование принятия
решений и достижения
это когда вы ставите человеку цель
определяете его ответственность а потом
делитесь с ним результатами В чём
разница между третьим и вторым уровнем
во втором уровне вы объясняете как
действовать и какой результат при этом
вы хотите получить вы как бы покупаете у
него этот результат за бонус или премию
а в третьем случае вы ставите цель а
цель как правило включает в себя много
промежуточных действий и результатов К
тому же Вы не объясняете этому
что делать и как е достигать Здесь вы
уже
делегируй соответственно Вы делитесь с
ним результатами либо в виде бонуса либо
в виде доли в прибыли или в виде опциона
на акции таким образом Когда вы уже
достигли третьего уровня делегирования
Вы опять упирается стеклянный потолок Ну
хотя это уже довольно высокий стеклянный
потолок который Привет ва к хорошим
доходам Вы будете очень зажиточным чеком
богатым человеком Но вы всё же ещё не
добьётесь значительных крутых достижений
для того чтобы наконец достичь самого
высокого уровня своей эффективности вам
нужно опять начать делать всё по-другому
И вам опять нужно будет делать что-то
другое чтобы перейти на этот уровень вам
нужно понять что существует два разных
вида деятельности это зарабатывание
денег и создание богатства как сказал в
своё время
фелер тот кто целый день занят
зарабатываем денег тот не имеет времени
на создание богатства для создания
богатства помимо вашей личной
эффективности талантов и команды вам
нужно ещё иметь везение и инструменты
позволяющие извлекать максимум из вашей
удачи А что такое удача удача или
везение - это благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств
посто уметь оказываться в нужное время в
нужном месте где есть очень крутые
жирные возможности но одних только
возможностей тоже мало важно знать и
уметь а также использовать инструменты
извлечения максимального эффекта из этих
возможностей А это уже
суперпозиция суперпозиция - это
целенаправленная деятельность по
созданию закономерного везения И
максимальному её использованию Но об
этом мы поговорим в моём следующем видео
если вам интересно подписывайтесь на мой
Telegram канал по ссылке которую я
оставлю внизу а я на этом прощаюсь с
вами Желаю вам удачи и всех благ
[музыка]